les images témoignent de la violence du
choc un peu avant 9 heures ce matin une
twingo empreinte l'a6 à contresens à
hauteur de montagny-lès-beaune et
provoque un carambolage avec six autres
véhicules
le conducteur un homme d'une soixantaine
d'années est tué sur le coup
deux autres sont grièvement blessés et
l'un d'eux des cèdres à son arrivée à
l'hôpital
face à l'ampleur de l'accident l'a6 est
immédiatement coupé malgré l'important
dispositif déployé l'intervention des
secours est délicate
la priorité est donnée sur les deux
personnes incarcérées dans le véhicule
et dans un même dans un même temps les
fonctions de la voiture en feu pour
lever le doute rapidement et s'assurer
qu'il n'y a pas d'autres personnes à
l'intérieur plusieurs centres de secours
sont mobilisés
l'évacuation des blessés graves
nécessitent même le recours à un
hélicoptère
en tout l'intervention aura duré trois
heures provoquant plus de 7 km de
bouchons la six a été rouverte sur deux
voies peu après 13 heures